hi everyone and uh
thanks for coming
my name is attila segeti and uh for the
past
two years two and a half years i've been
working at
oracle's java length tools and uh
i've well during that time mostly
working on
uh nashon which is uh our new
javascript runtime and well there was a
bunch of things to uh discover and learn
in uh in the in this journey so far and
we have a lot of
uh additional things ahead of us
but with the things that we uh with the
things that we achieved so far
i think we did hit on some uh some very
interesting experiences and some very
interesting results and
this is what i will be sharing with you
today
here um i hope you like bytecode
so um oh yeah this is our i work for
oracle
slides don't believe anything i say
don't purchase anything based on what i
told you
i might be lying i must i almost
certainly am
so so what's nashorn uh
we we started out with uh creating a
new javascript runtime on on top of the
jvm
oracle's jdk and before that sends jdk
since java 6 has been shipping with a
javascript runtime that was a version of
mozilla rhino
but it had its uh issue so there was a
decision to create a new one
nice thing about nashorn is that it is
completely open source all of the
development that we do
is in the open jdk repository there's no
there's no closed parts there's no uh
walled off secret sauce whatever
it does ship a standard part of the
oracle's
java since uh since java 8. so it's in
there you can just use it i will not
talk to you about how to use it you can
find this this is not the top
this is not in scope of this talk you
can access it from command line
you can use the javascript java x the
script apis
or you can also directly use the jdk nas
horn
api scripting package what's interesting
about it is that currently we do have no
interpreters and currently because
it's not out of the question that we
might want to have one in the future
for mostly for uh faster startup reasons
but we don't have it currently so
nashorn
starts out with compiling the source
code to java byte code and then running
that
it is fully ecmascript 5.1 compliant as
a matter of fact they have a tweet that
i couldn't find now and put it on a
slide where uh
about two years ago in a bar in
stockholm i was running the
ecma script 262 test suite that consists
of some 11.5 000 tests
and i have the
privilege of having the
having been the first person that had
all of those tests hundred percent pass
on his laptop
of course this also meant that i had two
tests that were not passing for a month
and i was working on that
damn two tests for a month before they
passed but that's just the way it is
nason is also security-minded although
we won't be talking about that another
reason to replace rhino was that that
porting uh hails back from java 1.1 days
and well it is not exactly
uh it does have no idea about the java
security model
with nash horn we we did make sure that
all the code generation the the the
typical issues with the
with the privileged code execution and
so on and so on that you have in java
where
we spend an amazing amount of time on
actually
getting this right it's uh
also our proving ground for invoke
dynamic uh
nash horn uses the invoke dynamic under
the covers
for uh it's to
basically have uh dynamic execution and
a fairly static runtime
and we are the
probably the biggest user of the invoke
dynamic right now and
we also serve as the as the
well grain of the sand in the
hot spot teams oyster to try to prod
them into producing a pearl
they're still not completely there but
they're getting there
so far we released it in java 8 and then
820 we did some security fixes and
8040 which is our current that march
is the big performance release and i
will mostly talk to you about this and
then java 9 will get everything that
java 8 has and
plus some why do we have this
performance focus and this talk will
mostly be about how to make a
fast fast dynamic language runtime on
the jvm because
well let's face it writing a slow
language runtime is fairly
easy getting a faster one is uh is
somewhat more complicated with a
throwback to the uh
kolmogorov complexity and the fortunate
fact that that function is actually
not computable we that's also called the
compiler
writer's job security theorem
which basically says you can spend a
lifetime writing optimizations
in the essay runtime you can spend a
lifetime writing optimizations in your
for for your system because you can
never prove that there are no
optimizations
left but which means i might actually
retire
one day and say that all my life i was
optimizing nass hernandez that might not
be the exact same
story that i would like to tell to my
grandkids so we'll see
so how are we doing uh the blue line
that you almost cannot see is rhino
and the line that's like normalized was
jdk 8 nashorn and currently the
green offshoots is the
nas horner 9 the jdk 9 performance same
thing that actually goes into
into 8240 we are back porting it in a
lock step
well things got faster
they always ask me so how fast is it and
that's that's a question you can all
only answer with that awful lot of
qualification right
next question is inevitably how about we
ate well
this is the state of the art versus v8
v8 is faster
it will probably always be faster we
don't want to really
we don't we don't claim to compete with
v8 as i said we want to have a modern
run time on the jvm we want to have
more many things but we are shooting for
fastest runtime
fastest javascript runtime there are
some things that
we cannot do that v8 can do v8 can do
things like
change the object layout while it's
garbage collecting
because you have this fun thing where
it's an actual live code from node.js
where they allocate an object literally
using curly braces
and then they start using it as an array
which is a completely
legal thing in javascript although you
would probably better communicate your
intent if you use the square brackets
instead of curly braces but a good thing
about v8 is that it can realize when
it's
doing garbage collection it needs to
inspect the objects anyway so it will
look at it and
say hey this thing looks a lot like an
array why don't i just change the
internal representation to be an array
us having to map things to objects on
the jv and we obviously can't do that
and there are some other things but
the good news is that number crunching
performance wise we are really catching
up that that's
actually something i wouldn't have said
a year ago but uh we
we we are getting there so what
optimizations what's the
what's the thing that things that you do
in your dynamic language today if you
really wanted to go
fast so things that we realize we need
to do
we do parameter type specialized
compilation which means that
if you have a function and you invoke it
with
int parameters and double parameters we
will actually compile two versions of
the code
yes there is a danger of combinatorial
explosion
no in practice it doesn't really happen
and
we are also very narrow with our
uh well to say this way our numeric
tower is
a very small tower we only do int long
double
and then object the other crazy thing
that we did was uh
we actually implemented the scheme for
onstack code replacement
with that that we needed for gradual the
optimization
again what is this about well in
javascript
when you retrieve a property from an
object or do
you retrieve an element from an array
you
have no clue statically
what its type will be it can be anything
right it can be an object it can be an
end you cannot tell until you retrieved
it
so what optimistic typing says is uh
let's be optimistic let's just presume
everything will be an end
just and then proceed happily with that
assumption
of course when it does not work out you
need to somehow
bail out of that particular code because
you've retrieved an element from an
array
and you told it's an int and you try to
and and
the rest of your code in bytecode re
says
i add you try to do an integer add on
them right you cannot have anything
that's not an
int on the stack the java verifier will
not let you
in the first place so you need to then
take that
that version of your code you need to
bail out of it somehow
recompile a new version that says well i
know that that array is known to return
doubles so i will now treat whatever
comes back as double and instead of it i
will use the add
and then you need to keep running with
that we'll get to it we have static code
analysis which is funny because the
dynamic language
and there is a slew of ordinary compile
ordinary
compiler optimizations those that you
can read about in books on
writing a c compiler you also take
advantage of frontline context during
compilation which is one of the more
inspired things that i think i did in a
in a in in a past it was quite
quite quite funny when uh i figured out
we can do this and it was
even more funny when it worked so
parameter type specialized compilation
as i said if you have a function in
javascript say
you're squaring a number and you invoke
it with an int and you invoke it with a
double
then what happens is that we will
actually compile two versions of the
code
oh and by the way we are doing lazy
compilation
uh this function square it gets parsed
it doesn't get compiled it's only on the
first invocation with particular
parameters if we don't have that type of
specialization that's when we will
actually
go to the trouble and and actually
compile that version of the code
i can actually demonstrate this pretty
easily i will be switching between
live coding a lot here
so here's the exact same code oops
yep and let's just
do let's just put some markers here that
will show you how things go
so if you just run this code in a pretty
damn manner
then obviously you get this result now
if you
add some logging for
recompilation is this font large enough
i can make things larger do you see it
okay cool
roger okay
yeah maybe we need to balance between
size and actually seeing something
okay is this better okay
so as you can see the program starts
running
and oh actually crazily enough even the
program is lazy
it shouldn't be but it's just we didn't
want to special case it
so it prints this first line and then it
actually says hey i need a
type specialization of the square
function
that will take an intense and return and
end
how do how does it know it will be
returning an end
well it doesn't that's the fun fun part
is that
that's also something that based on your
input parameters you might have an
optimistic guess at what
return type might be and that can
actually also evolve over time it's just
the initial guess it knows that we'll be
receiving an
end but that it will be returning an end
is actually a guess
so as you can see it compiled the int
version here
printed its result and then
it compiled the double version here and
as you can see it actually says
okay i'm compiling a double i want to
get back an int but then a
weird thing will happen here you see
this rewrite exception that's actually
telling it
i am trying to return an in from this
function but what i got
back instead is a double so at this
point
it needs to regenerate the code
so that it returns a double and then
return that
if we dig deeper
nice thing about nasa is that if you
want to play with this you can just do
whatever i did
pc is shorthand for
print code
you can see what it does
so we have the int version which
you know loads the argument does a
multiplication which is not an ordinary
multiplication mind you
it's a dynamically linked something and
returns the result
and then you also have the double
version
which as you can see will
be returning a double so
and of course if i did a version that
took an object as its argument then
the compiled version would be this naive
javascript which just takes its argument
does the javascript conversion to a
number
and it does it twice and
multiplies and returns the result the
reason it has to do it twice sorry i'm
just
going through a slide the reason it has
to do twice is because javascript
objects can have
can customize their number
representation and it can be stateful so
you cannot just retrieve it once and use
it twice
that's another benefit of being able to
use primitives is that you know that
they
cannot have any of this fancy business
going under the covers right and int
will always have the same value
no matter what and objects being mutable
oh well
what's funny is that uh and it's
actually a new new slide that i insert
based on the conversation
yesterday is that this thing works with
higher order functions too
as uh js function under the hood is
actually a holder of all of
its type specializations and we
propagate the types
from the top so if you take the
the simplest possible higher order
function that basically says
apply this to an argument apply this
function to an argument
and you invoke it then what this will do
is it will generate
two specializations of apply one that
takes an
object and an int and another that takes
an object and a double and i need to
really reverse the order of the
arguments there on the slide
and it will be invoking f
and one version will be invoking f with
an int and the other will be invoking
f with a double so they will actually
end up invoking square with an intense
square with a double
so it just works out really nicely as i
said i need to
actually in my example code i have this
right
i have it here this is the exact same
code
so if we compile this thing
we will see that
we have a version of apply that that uh
takes
takes some end returns and int and takes
an object that's that
that's the function right and it will
just uh
load its object argument and do a
dynamic call on it and it will say i
will pass it an int
and expect an ins to be returned and
when this executes
that's ex that's when we will first
compile the square
version with an int and then
we also will have a version with that
takes a double and
hopes that it can return an end it does
not know what's the type
of the it doesn't know what will the
square function return if you pass it a
double
it it hopes back for an int but it can
fail
and it will actually fail so you will
see that we will
have yet another version of apply
compiled after a while
that at this point it says if i pass a
double to this function it will be
returning a double
so it just gradually discovers the types
as it goes
all right so we also do
uh the optimization on arithmetic
overflow because in javascript we are
not allowed to overflow javascript
specification wise it has no idea about
uh about
it it has no idea whatsoever about ins
it's completely defined in terms of
doubles
so using gins is an optimization that we
do
so if you take a square function and you
actually pass it something that when
multiplied
will overflow the int then
the square function itself will have to
will have to be optimized
and yeah
do i have this yes i do
so first we have takes an ends returns
on int
and then after it failed with this input
it will
become more conservative it will say
well you know the square function if
invoked with an end might actually
return along
so it will load its arguments widen them
to
two longs and then perform a long
multiplication and return that
all right so
the invoke dynamic that we'll link to
for the multiplication actually is
something that
invokes javaline math multiply exact
these are new methods in
java line math that throw arithmetic
exceptional overflows and that point we
catch those we
we perform the multiplication as longs
in the
in the in the newly constructed
exception as you can see we do a long x
times long y there
and we throw back a new exception which
also contains an
identifier of the location in the code
where this thing happened
we must perform the operation return the
result because
well all of this must be transparent
with regard to the execution of the
program right that we are internally
throwing exceptions
regenerating code from the point of the
external user who runs the code this
must not be observable
we have similar the optimizing
compilation for property types
if uh sorry yeah for types of properties
if you're retrieving a property foo from
a
for instance here we'll again have an
assumption that it's um
in then we generate the dynamic invoker
which invokes the function
invokes the property and the return
value it tries to treat it as an int and
if it's not it will throw an exception
to regenerate the code
so sometimes if
it gets really widened then
if this a foo is actually a double
then we will end up we will end up
generating a really nice version of the
code that says okay if it's a double
then i will just use double
multiplication here and uh
this is this is a an example of of
a static type analysis working hand in
hand with optimistic typing to make sure
that
uh the the code is as nice as as nice as
possible because double
double multiplication cannot overflow
within the javascript semantic right
it can become infinite though
all right so how do we do this
how do we de-optimize running code
because normally
the usual usual way to do this is
you need to recompile a new version of
the on the fly but
what's more complicated is that you need
to replace your running code on top of
the stack
now runtimes that do this are obviously
solving this problem
our issue was that we try to solve it in
a way where
you don't we don't do any magic tricks
we want to do it in completely
java specification compliant way
not using any vm tricks
so we did achieve this for the pure
bytecode solution so it runs on any jvm
not just oracle's jvm
as i said nason is in open jdk so any
open jdk licensee can take it
and use it on their system it does not
have to be it does not have to be
oracle's uh
hotspot so what we did you so it saw it
that we throw an exception the type
assumptions are too narrow
and whenever function that can be the
optimize is linked we use the
invoke dynamics try catch combinator
to call catch this exception the caller
it must be in the caller because we need
to
jump out of the function that needs to
be the optimize we need to remove it
from the stack
so we need to jump back to the caller
the caller catches the exception derails
into the compiler
it generates two versions of the code
the new
version of the code with a wider type at
that point
it installs it wherever it needs to be
installed for later discovery if some
other site also invokes the same
function
but we also need to compile a separate
one-shot continuation version
of that code as well and then we need to
invoke that guy
to resume execution as if nothing
happened
this looks like this this is a typical
example of a rest of method in my
in in the previous example for a few
times two
is we take asm and in order to not make
our life difficult
we just generate the same code as for
the normal version of the
function we don't do anything fancy we
just basically
feed azm with the same instruction
visitor
sequence except at the very top we put a
go to to a very late label and that very
late label on the bottom
is something that takes this rewrite
exception which contains the full
encapsulation of the state
that we captured at the point of the of
the failure we need to
recompile it restores the
local variables and then it
restores the state of the stack from
those local variables
applies any type conversions that might
need
which might be tricky because maybe you
had maybe you were initializing an
array of ins and one of your expressions
became a double and you actually need to
have an array of doubles right now at
which point we
you might have a value on the stack that
we just transparently and nonchalantly
just replace from an array of fins to an
array of doubles now
and after all that was said and done
like a cherry on the top you put the
return value which is now a double
and then you jump back to whatever is
the rest of your execution
so that's how the rest of method works
i'll show you an example hey
okay
all right oh man
the computer is behaving
okay i can't believe this looked like
the presentation gods
not with us and this otherwise trusty
macbook pro just decided to
kind of look up maybe it's just the
display problem let me see
well it's still
okay i can still go through my slides so
maybe that's really
sufficient so in extremely simple terms
what
what it does is that we have this
tricatch combinator we say okay let's
invoke the function and if we get the
rewrite exception this is all
put in a in a dynamic in the call site
in the caller
then if you get the exception then you
do the thing which to do the thing is
recompile the functions through the new
version
in a you know store it with the
immutable function data for later
invocations
you need to invalidate all the already
linked call sites that were linking to
the or
potentially old version of the code
including this call site
and they need to generate continuation
version and you need to jump into it
however uh there's some tricky stuff
like you want to recompile and
what if you need to recompile a a
recursive function
a mutually recursive function that can
have another copy of it
an arbitrary number of stack frames
further down
we don't want to exhaust the stack on
cascading recompiles because
if you de-optimize something and running
the rest of method it itself can hit
another
point where it itself will be optimized
and so on for that
we actually what we do is that instead
of invoking the continuation
we return the method handle that's the
continuation and we fold it into a
method handle exact invoker
i don't expect that you don't
necessarily understand all of that i'm
just trying to illustrate the
the amount of stuff that we needed to
take care of and
and then we go and bother the vm hotspot
the the vm team and the team that works
on method handles we come to them is
like
hey guys there's the sketch combinator
it performs really poorly and they're
like yeah whoever uses that oh well we
use it everywhere
oh you do yes and we need it to be fast
well it has a fast path up to eight
arguments that's not good enough we have
some benchmarks and this is javascript
where people routinely pass
i don't know 15 16 arguments the
functions yeah it's ugly but who can
prevent them right
so we need the fast the fast pass for
the catch combinator to be
fast no matter how many arguments and
what their types are
and then they go away and grumble and
come back a few months later and say
here
of course getting right all of this it
really scrapes at your sanity at the
time this is my tweet from a few uh
weeks ago when i was working on
nassau sparser so that it can skip we do
a lot of recompilation so
it's nice to skip already in the parser
things that you don't need like nested
functions
and i have this great board game katulo
gloom that i like to play with my wife
and kids
i i said i can start illustrating my
work with the with
with the cards from it where you like
inflict uh
the card game is about inflicting the
misery on
on on members of a family that are put
in your care
and this is one of those like delve to
the minus 20
points in the right hand side you have
also this like little icon for
for special insanity modifiers
and this is my colleague marcus uh in
deep thinking about some
javascript object shape problems
so come work for us
nason has an extremely simple type
hierarchy in long double an object and
we just
we any of those can be wide and then
it's monotonic so we can never
end up with a with a circular thing
while the optimizing the optimization we
really think about is really just a
stepping in a
lattice of uh type tuples because every
point in your
function that can be optimized has a
current type right so if you have like
four points
you all start with like in int
everything is an int i'm so happy i'm so
optimistic everything will be
and everything will be great and then
you'd optimize and say well maybe the
first argument was a js for long
was a long but everything else will
still be an end and then
maybe something else they optimize so
what happens if you have an
input to your function and you try to
run it and sometimes you have the
your data flow pipeline which is at
first is int
wide and then whenever something gets
stuck in it you widen it a little bit
and carry on
and eventually you hit the point in the
lattice that
works for all the data that you have
thrown so far on your
into a function well maybe some million
iterations later something will come
again that will widen it but hey the
machinery is still there you will do it
then but
usually things stabilize and then you
have the
super pessimistic bottom of the lattice
on the right which is everything is an
object
sorry sometimes you don't need to be
optimistic like
if you are doing a multiplication of two
numbers but you know that you feed it
into something that truncates the
value to uh sign 32-bit int then
we don't bother again a nice place a
nice reason for using static
static type analysis is that if you if
you have this pattern it's using asm.js
to force the arguments to be ends we
just do on an
imol here and don't carry and don't
worry about the overflows because
they're chopped off by the or zero
anyway
oh and then there's this thing where
okay so are we in compile time we are
recompiling code but are we in compile
time
well we're not javascript does not
define compile time and
runtime it just says here's the source
code
execute it right anything that's in
between
specification doesn't care
and what we can do here is that
one of the realizations was that hey
it's a dynamic language
you jump into a compiler but you're
actually running
you have the values of all the variables
and objects in the lexical scope you can
use them yay so what we do
is that we can actually skip several of
these steps in the compile
in in the type lattice for instance if i
invoke a function
that takes an object and i retrieve two
properties from it
o dot x and o dot y at first i will
start with the assumption that
x is in y is in and their multiplication
will be an end
so i have the my type lattice has this
three ends
at starting point and then i invoke it
with this
object litter over both x and y are
doubles so
when i retrieve o.x
i will fail to retrieve it as an int i
need to recompile the function so i
derail the execution into the compiler
but what i do now is that
naively i would just say well okay
autotext taxes are double now but oh
dude why might still be an int
i will be optimistic about it and then i
start running the new version and the
total why
also fails being an int and then i need
to recompile again okay oh damn it okay
all the twice also double let's
recompile again with this in mind and
carry on
so that's two recompilations but we cut
that down to one because
when we recompile o dot x we actually
tell the compiler to
try to evaluate side effect free
expressions so if o is just an ordinary
local variable and the y is a property
with no getter so it doesn't have any
side effects you know it's just a field
getter
it will actually peek into it and if it
says well that's a double as well i
would just
emit the code to be a double so we curb
the enthusiasm
so to speak of the compiler if we if
if we know
and it really pays off when you have
things like this this is actually the
octane box 2d benchmark that does uh
things like this now imagine if these
are all doubles
and we would always just presume that
one of these is a double and the rest
can still be ins
and you would recompile the function
evaluate the next expression oh damn it
i need to recompile again and go back
and just
it would it would crunch through it but
it would be slow it would be horrible
for warm-up time
and with this basically whenever it hits
recompilation it will try to
peak at the values of other available uh
variables and just
try to evaluate them and and and
preemptively optimize basically
so uh static type inference here dynamic
language runtime
is also a
sort of an oxymoron right except it
isn't because
at the end of the day we are targeting a
static language runtime
well static virtual machine sorry uh
jvm is statically typed it does
it has a separate operands for
arithmetic on ins and arithmetic and
longs or atleticon doubles and so on
so what we do is uh we do actually
calculate types of expressions and local
variables
and we do a bunch of propaga we do the
propagation as you could
imagine uh it's it's standard compiler
stuff it's not terribly
exciting except for the fact that uh we
did it and we saw
extremely we saw extreme benefits
after i spent probably three months from
january to march this year writing the
static type uh
inferencer uh for uh intra
it works within a single function for
nashorn and the number crunching
performance uh
and number crunching uh numbers they
went through the roof really
um crypto benchmark other benchmarks
that are
that are heavy on calculations like
box2d as well they just
got amazingly faster
and what's super frustrating is that i
have a bunch of example code that i was
going to live
demo to you right now but i cannot
comment top out of my presentation
so i guess we're stuck with me speaking
and you believe in what i say although i
had the slide saying that i'm lying so
so there's a we we need to handle a
bunch of tricky control flow situations
that you don't really think about a lot
like
control flow into catch blocks right
okay so it's like okay how boring is
this but it has to be done
it's the problem problem with java the
the blessing really with the java byte
code is that it needs to be statically
verifiable
so it means that you need to be able to
have a definite type for a local
variable at any time
so what we do is that if you can enter
the catch block or just
fall out from a try catch in such a
manner that the value of a
might be a double then you must ensure
that no matter how the execution reaches
the catch block it has to be a double
now we start it with an int we define it
as an int but when you enter the try
block we just insert like a synthetic
widening
into a double but on the other hand it's
so wasteful because if it doesn't go
into the catch block now
i treat it as a double whereas i could
treat it as an int
so what we do here is that we keep two
live values
for the variable so the way our storage
for local variables is is constructed is
that the variable i
will actually have assigned two bytecode
slots what one for its int value and one
for its double value where it's
executing in a try block
and whenever it's
whenever it has a live int value
it will be used so if you print the a
there it will actually
in the first line it will actually use
the int value and you assign it another
int value what happens here is that we
store the int value into the in slot
we store the widened double value into
the double slot and
still both of them are live and then
when the a
equals 2.1 comes around we say well it's
now defined as double and the
int value is now dead and then when you
but this all ensures that when you enter
the catch block
the int value is dead there anyway but
you will always have a live double value
even if you
somehow went to the catch blog because
one of the prints through an exception
which it won't do ever but
just for illustrating purposes so these
are things that
need to be solved because of javastatic
verification of types and because we
didn't want
to just stupidly widen the value into
int for the sake of the catch block
if it's not necessarily true it works
for other things as well not just catch
blocks right you can have an if block
where
if through something and then you have a
long gif block that's manipulating
variables
but they are never used outside or you
use differently outside so
we try to try to keep the value as
narrow as possible so
here's another example in if block if
you assign i
equals one then the y will actually use
the in int value and
then we exit the x block then you need
to widen it and so this is
real classical control flow join points
type
type coordination but
again it's not specifically interesting
because of the fact that we do it it's
uh
it's not supposed to be interesting
because it is what it is it's it's all
the type theory stuff it's interesting
to see that
we did this in our jv and based dynamic
language
and we did reap quite big performance
benefits from doing it
which again might not be terribly
surprising but at least now we know that
it works
we do a bunch of death code elimination
as well
we did have to use something that's
called type liveness
oh i spent maybe a week like in a shower
during the runs
trying to figure out a
liveness analysis algorithm on asd
turns out you can't or maybe you can but
it's it
it would be horrible that's because
aliveness analysis always goes backwards
uh in in the control flow and asds are
not really
well geared for that so um
it's not a luxury really because
javascript has this brain that thing
where
if you declare a variable within a block
it's a live outside of the block as well
so in this case it's fine x can remain
being an
int because it's not used outside but if
you do
but if you do this you actually use it
outside
it actually needs to cope with the fact
that okay so
let's imagine that we didn't say i less
than 10 but i less than
something that i don't know what it is
maybe we we didn't even enter the loop
body so
x needs to be widened to object but when
do you widen it again the static
uh type proving for the java verifier
makes it really hard
to eliminate like widening of x to
object on
every back edge of the loop which would
be horrible if you had to do it
but we don't have to so that's why it's
not a luxury to do
i don't have time to talk about a lot of
things as a matter of fact i think i'm
completely out of time
uh but uh if you want to stick for
another three minutes i can just
tell you real quick uh what is it that
we want to
go towards with this right now this is a
nassau's compiler pipeline
the code gen at the right is like a more
bold
arrow and it is
it is where the heavy lifting right now
happens
code for optimistic operations
continuation handling self-assignment
stores whatever
we do all of that there but i'm not
happy about it what i want to do
is i want to move it in a previous
phase of the compiler pipeline doesn't
exist yet that they call
the dynamic code gen that would be
creating something like a dynamically
typed byte code
which would look something like
this so if you have a function square
you could emit something like
low dex load y multiple return and it
would be the
our library that would convert that into
what you have on the right side figure
out whether there is any optimism that
needs to be done
and emit the final byte code so
the benefits of this reuse right
v8 has almost a million lines of code
nashville has
270 000 right now and
the reason for that is that we use a lot
of everything in the jvm
now imagine if we can extract a lot of
things we have in nash horn
and give it to you as a reusable library
for
building dynamic languages that's what i
want to do my elevator pitch for what i
want to do in the future with this
project is like
llvm only for dynamic languages on the
on the jvm basically give you this
almost
byte code except you can use symbolic
identifiers and you don't really care
about types
and it will run your static type
inference prove as much types as it can
and deal with the optimistic
recompilation for all the types that it
cannot prove statically
that's my ultimate goal for this
and these are various examples oh
lexical scope getters right
almost every dynamic language has
lexicals lexical scoping
jvm doesn't have it uh that's also
something that we can just uh
just fix for you so in in your in your
thing
you can just uh be getting uh
you can just say like load x and you
don't have to worry where the x is
defined in your lexical scope we can
just
make sure that if it's outside of your
current local scope
then instead of a local load from
bytecode slot we can
we can do an optimistic getter from your
scope
and so on and so on so that's uh
that's the thing summary
is some things are really hard to do
here
static analysis the whole thing with it
i specialized on stack replacement
i didn't even talk to you about array
representation
uh optimization of built-in like ray
push pop string
carat and things like that
this whole optimistic onstack
replacement
solution and we have solved a bunch of
these problems with nason and would like
to offer them
eventually as a reusable library and
what we also need for that is a suitable
code representation
as it turns out asd is too high level
jvm bytecode is too statically type we
need something in between that hits the
sweet spot which would be
which would be this uh in my imagination
something that is very similar to
bytecode except that you don't have to
worry about this bunch of
bunch things that i just explained to
you all right that's
all i had apologies for overshooting and
thanks for listening